hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the great pleasure of
sitting this morning with Michael
Shermer who is the publisher of skeptic
magazine and Jeremy riss return guest on
the Dark Horse podcast who has a degree
in physics he runs the alien scientist
Channel and he is an expert in Next
Generation Science and Technology
welcome to both of you thanks for having
us hey thanks so we are gathered
together to uh talk about
belief and skepticism and to navigate
the difficulty of figuring out what it
is we should believe rationally
in a moment as confusing as this current
one and I know all three of us have I
believe a great deal of alignment about
wanting to believe only those things
that are analytically well supported by
evidence but that has caused us to reach
very different conclusions on some
important issues of the day so I don't
want this to be viewed as a debate I'm
not sure how productive debate is I
think it would be wise if we viewed this
as a friendly discussion to the deaf
but uh anyway Gentlemen let's let's
um let's start out in an area
that is uh uh has a great deal of
interest at the current moment and that
has got all three of our attention the
issue of what were once called UFOs that
are now called
uaps Michael do you want to set us in
motion on that topic
yeah sure start with the name uaps uh
unidentified Ariel phenomena now it's
morph again into unidentified anomalous
phenomenon uh this is what Steve Pinker
calls the euphemism treadmill when the
word becomes pejorative uh the words
change uh UFOs have always been
associated with kind of Fringe elements
of science or pseudoscience and you know
people being abducted by aliens and
aliens mutilating cattle and all this
kind of stuff that that's made most
scientists avoid the subject entirely so
UAP is is I guess a welcome change
because it is an interesting question
but what's the question so here I divide
uh between two different questions are
they out there have they come here that
they be an alien so like for example
often when I express my skepticism that
uaps represent extraterrestrial
intelligence as people will say so
you're saying we're all alone in the
universe no no that's not what I'm
saying that's a different question I
support the seti program I support the
Galileo project I'm on the Galileo
project team uh you know I think it's
you know very probable that we're not
alone
and the cosmos 100 billion galaxies
hundreds of billions of galaxies Each of
which has hundreds of billions of stars
each of these Stars has planets and on
and on you crunch the numbers in the
Drake equation you get a number that's
very unlikely to be zero or one we're
the only ones but that's a different
question from have they come here you
know it's a pretty vast empty it's
mostly just empty space between the
Stars chances of them finding this uh
much less being bipedal primates that
look a lot like us and have human
concerns that you know these are just
very unlikely but I would be willing to
change my mind and say yeah okay we have
been visited if the evidence was
proportional to that claim extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidences
Carl Sagan famously made famous in
Cosmos wasn't his line initially but
um that is to say everybody agrees on
both sides of the discussion that the
discovery that we are not alone would be
one of the biggest discoveries in the
history of Science History of all of
humanity that would be spectacular I
would love to know that that's true but
I I don't want to believe in things that
have to be believed in to be true I want
it to actually be true and so how good
is the evidence for this extraordinary
claim and it is not extraordinary it's
not even very ordinary it's mostly
anecdotal a few grainy videos and blurry
photographs and things like that
and uh you know does not convince me
that I can drop my skepticism reject the
null hypothesis as it were that were not
being visited and say that we are being
visited because the evidence is so
overwhelming uh I just don't see that
yet
and uh
let's say that the evidence were to
cross that threshold what would that
have to look like for you to um to reach
a different conclusion well my latest
analogy for that uh is the Chinese
spyballoon you know when that that story
first broke in April I thought maybe you
know the pictures weren't all that clear
and the news reporting was was also not
clear but within hours it's like we we
had better videos and photographs and
then when the few days we had jets that
were scrambled to take close-up
photographs of it and video of it it was
unmistakably clear there it was and then
our the pilot shot it down there it is
in the ocean uh you know and at that
point no one's asking about the
credentials of the pilot who shot it
down so like a lot of the like
Congressional hearings about the uaps
everybody talks about the credentials of
the eyewitnesses you know always a
general he's a captain he's a you know
he's the mayor of the towns the governor
you know what none of that's relevant if
you have evidence no who cares what the
the credentials of the pilot that shot
down the Chinese Bible it doesn't matter
if the Spy balloon is real president
United States issued a statement that
Pentagon Secretary of Defense Secretary
of State
covered it
yeah well argument for Authority yeah I
mean I can't I I haven't seen the
Chinese spy balloon with my own eyes and
it didn't come over Southern California
here so but I trust the enough of the
authorities to assume it's real that
that was not a fake
all right fair enough
um I will say I heard you
well go ahead Jeremy sorry if the fact
that it does it has been completely
blown to bits and not recovered I'm also
not uh surprised with uh given the
territory that it was shot down over uh
like ice field
um and the fact that it was a spy
balloon shot with a Sidewinder missile
so
um yeah it's again I don't I don't have
a problem with that I don't think that
that's the best evidence either
um I've looked into a lot of the UFO
stuff myself and and it's
you know what are your opinions on some
of the top uh people out there in this
field right now uh who a lot of them
have turned out to be grifters and
people who push uh you know fake stories
for profit it seems it seems like a um a
business uh of sorts uh to be able to
publish fake information and
um and then profit off the dissemination
of that as everyone goes crazy sharing
you know that and and spreading it
um and I guess the military sort of
doesn't have a problem with those sort
of people because they're essentially
great counterintelligence assets to the
to them
um so uh you know well the you have the
head of
um the head of uh the FAA recently you
know chiming in I think the head of NASA
is chimed in on this and said oh I
haven't seen anything like this uh so
therefore that they're you know these
things can't be real or they're not they
don't exist but it's it's they would
have said the same thing in the 19 80s
about the B2 flying around and all the
sightings that people were seeing of
this the spycraft that were not yet
disclosed back then exactly so I think
it's much more likely that what we're
seeing our next Generation uh
Technologies
um including some things that might not
even be physical uh some people have uh
compared it to a cat chasing a laser
around and saying wow it defies the laws
of physics I can't catch it you know
it's going so fast and uh and and
whipping around when in reality you can
play three-dimensional games with lasers
by just crossing two of them in space uh
it ionizes the air where the two lasers
cross and you can they they were
demonstrating this in Japan in 2011
um making full on uh Graphics in the air
using laser induced plasmas
um so we are already uh in heated
agreement on this UAP issue this
delicious episode of dark horses
sponsored by the truly delicious mud
water which makes a fantastic drink it's
spicy and chock full of adaptogenic
mushrooms and ayurvedic herbs with one
seventh caffeine of a cup of coffee you
get the energy without the anxiety
Jitters or crash if you like the routine
of making and drinking a cup of warmth
in the morning but don't drink coffee or
trying to cut down try mud water that's
m-u-d-w-t-r
each ingredient was added with intention
it has cacao and chai for just a hint of
caffeine lion's mane mushrooms to
support Focus cordyceps to help you
support physical performance chaga and
Rishi to support your immune system and
cinnamon which is a potent antioxidant
mud water also makes a non-dairy creamer
out of coconut milk and MCT and a
sweetener out of coconut palm sugar
lucuma a fruit of an Andean tree used by
the Inca to add if you prefer those
options or you can mix and match add a
bit of their coconut milk and MCT
creamer with some honey from bees real
bees or use mud Waters lucuma and
coconut palm sugar sweetener and skip
the bees entirely mud water is a hundred
percent USDA organic non-GMO gluten-free
vegan and kosher certified
mud Waters flavor is warm and spicy with
a hint of chocolate plus Masala chai
which includes Ginger and cardamom
nutmeg and cloves it is also delicious
blended into a smoothie try it with
banana and Ice milk or a milk-like
substance mint a touch of honey and
cacao nibs to get 15 off go to
mudwater.com Dark Horse pod to support
the show use Dark Horse pod for 15 off
mud water
our second sponsor for this episode is
House of macadamias tree nuts are
delicious and nutritious and generally
high in fat and low in carbohydrates
unlike what various food pyramids and
government agencies might have led you
to believe high fat low carb foods are
increasingly understood to be both
satiating and good for you each species
of nut is different however requiring a
special mindset and if you are that sort
appropriate Footwear
clogs for some waiting shoes for others
regardless of what shoes you have
available though like us you are likely
to find macadamias are the best nut
there is macadamia nuts take a very long
time to grow and because they are both
rare and highly sought after they have
the dubious distinction of being the
world's most expensive nut between the
taste and health benefits though they're
worth it they have even fewer
carbohydrates than most other nuts which
makes them a perfect snack for breaking
a daily fast and controlling blood
glucose they're also uniquely rich in
omega-7s including especially palmettoic
acid and unsaturated fat that has been
linked to Natural collagen production
fat loss and heart health
and House of macadamias is intent on
making this amazing food accessible to
everyone
they have partnered with more than 90
farmers in Africa and now make
one-of-a-kind vegan keto and paleo
snacks these include their dark
chocolate dipped macadamias and a
delicious assortment of bars made with
45 macadamia nuts in flavors
including salted caramel and chocolate
coconut our favorite product of theirs
however is the simple salted macadamias
made with namibian sea salt they're
amazing we love them and we think you
will too House of macadamias also makes
a delicious macadamia nut oil which is a
hundred percent cold pressed rich in
monounsaturated fatty acids and has a
higher smoke point than Olive Oil so
it's well suited to high heat cooking
and baking and they've got great new
macadamia nut milk available in
individual packets that travel well our
house of academias Highly recommends
House of macadamias for all your
macadamic needs
for our limited time House of macadamias
is offering listeners a free box of
their best seller namibian sea salted
macadamia nuts worth 35 bucks with your
purchase at
houseofbacademias.com
Darkhorse 20 off your whole order with
code Darkhorse I believe I am not uh I
am not exaggerating to say that all
three of us believe we are very likely
not alone in the universe would be very
excited to discover that we were being
visited but find ourselves deeply
skeptical of the evidence that we have
been shown which so far is Best
explained by uh terrestrial phenomena
and
um
portrayal rather than aliens visiting us
and doing things that are Beyond such an
explanation is that fair
yeah I I picture Marco Rubio finally
getting permission to go into one of
these warehouses where the you know the
spaceships are being kept and it's like
the next generation of the stealth
bomber fight or something like that he's
like oh this is what we're working on
yeah well I can't tell the public about
that no no of course you can't and then
he's then he comes out and said nothing
to see here folks oh no he's lying he's
covering up the aliens
yeah it's it's something to do along
those lines I would I would say uh
invisibility technology uh has been a
hot hotly studied topic out at Area 51
it's it's was project rainbow was
started there in 1950s and uh to to
specifically investigate invisibility
technology so we've been this is now
we're now in generations of metamaterial
since the 1980s and 90s when the the
term was first coined so
um what we have in terms of invisibility
technology and then you have to think
about and something else out there uh
that's thousands of years more advanced
than us
um I'd like to compare it to a Star Trek
episode uh called who watches the
Watchers
um where basically the Star Trek is
they're observing this Bronze Age
civilization and they're using um
invisibility cloak from their
observation platform and then one day
the power thing go goes down and these
things these uh beans they're they're
hiding they're hidden
um rock facade goes away and uh they're
exposed and and um they try to go down
and tell the Bronze Age civilization you
know that hey we're just scientists and
trying to study you and they don't
understand they're like you guys are
gods and no you came from the heavens
and the stars and then like you know so
it's it just starts this whole religion
and mythology with the people in the
Star Trek episode as uh they they uh
interact with them more and they realize
that we're just doing more damage
and uh if I had a nickel for every time
that happened to me man
but you know I think
yeah go ahead yeah but it's it is
interesting
I guess I guess I'd one response to that
is before we invoke that those are kind
of explanations that it's our technology
or Russian or Chinese or something like
that
um a lot of these videos I think have
more mundane explanations they're just
balloons or it's the way the camera
mounted on the bottom of the plane was
rotating and you know the floor effects
and those sorts of things I think can't
explain at least some of the video
effects as you know Midwest has been all
over this
um and there's a video going around of
Scott Kelly the astronaut and pilot at
that mass one of these NASA hearings
where they're talking about uaps and he
gets up and gets his little speech and
he says because people say well these
Pilots are trained they know what to
look for they can assess size and
distance he goes let me tell you about
pilots and our ability to assess things
he goes when I was up in the no it was
his brother I think who was in the space
shuttle and they were about to close the
cargo bay doors and one of the other
astronauts said wait there's something
floating around in the cargo bay we
better get that thing it's an instrument
or a tool or something we left in there
before we close it we better go get it
and then they they're looking at the
thing and they realize that's the space
station 80 miles away
yeah it's just like and he talks about
Pilots he said I was up in the plane and
my co-pilot goes oh my God there's a UAP
we better go check it out so they whip
around and go back in some Bart Simpson
balloon and he had a bunch of stories
like this Pilots want to Rendezvous with
another pilot and turns out it's a buoy
on the ocean distances are hard to
measure you know it's hard to know
what's going on Illusions are common
There's Hope there are lots of ways that
people could see something that isn't
what it appears to be and that uh
problem gets exponentially worse if
something is interested in misleading us
at the level of our perceptions which is
unfortunately a real possibility
um uh for for various reasons I mean
including one reason that you might want
to mislead us is to get people to tune
this topic out ultimately to create a
lot of excitement about uaps that aren't
uaps so that people get over it because
there is something to know so you know
it becomes a Hall of Mirrors when one is
trying to properly evaluate
um the the evidence in this realm which
then raises the next question I mean we
do all roughly agree on this one where
we may differ is what is it in light of
the pollution of the information
environment and the many different ways
that terrestrial phenomena could be
mistaken for extraterrestrial phenomena
what is it that each of us would accept
as evidence that we actually were being
visited
hmm
well okay so just one response to that
is because like I I can imagine someone
in DARPA or the CIA sitting back there
going they think it's the aliens again
this is great this is such a great
misdirection from what we want them to
know because we don't want the Russians
are supporting aliens and UFOs and not
uh yeah and they're they're in
perception on it is through a different
set of goggles it's through a colored
you know colored glasses yeah now
because of that it's great
yeah I could see that the other idea
that the hypothesis that the Russian or
Chinese technology and somehow the
Russians or Chinese have developed
um like anti-gravity propulsion systems
or you know these kinds of technologies
that are like decades or centuries ahead
of what we have that's not possible
that's just not how it works you know we
steal their secrets they steal our
secrets you know history history of
technology and science is very
cumulative uh you know no one gets very
far ahead of anybody else ever you know
even so the examples I use like the
Manhattan Project the most secret
project ever you know the Russians stole
our secrets and had a bomb within two or
three years if there isn't yeah
aliens if they're not hiding aliens
because that was according to the
witnesses classified two levels higher
than the Manhattan Project so
oh well okay but also what else would be
true if the Russians had this super
technology wouldn't we see it in Ukraine
and we don't see anything like that in
fact they're just pretty primitive what
they're doing there so Witnesses it
seems like they're clearing out their
old war inventory for something new Yeah
well yeah I don't know
that may well be part of the explanation
for our involvement as well is that we
have a lot of weapons that sit in
warehouses and from a business
perspective clearing those warehouses
means a a bull market for new weapons I
I have been led to understand that that
is a motivating factor by people inside
the industry so that frightens me
um and it could be that something
parallel is going on I mean the you mean
like the military-industrial complex
precisely yeah yeah it really looks like
there is something to that RFK Junior's
been talking about that but you know
that goes back to Eisenhower I think
that's true
so let me just say from my perspective
there is maybe only one slam dunk answer
to the question of what I would accept
as evidence
um that we were being visited
and it's the one that is conspicuously
absent from the discussion almost
entirely which is the biology yeah if
you were to show an actual alien pilot
to a competent team of biologists and
they were allowed to ask natural
questions to run experiments that they
believed worthy of running a competent
team of biologists
very easily rule out
um the two possibilities that would
um have to be ruled out one of them
being that what is in front of them is
not in fact biological and the other is
that what is in front of them is
biological but not earth-based if right
so we figured if they ruled out the
earth-based and the non-biological we
would be left with a creature whose
complexity was too great to be faked and
um whose nature was uh most easily
explained by an extraterrestrial origin
which is I think why we're not talking
about it because
Stephen Greer and the Atacama skeleton
remember but it turned out to be just a
mummified little a fetus or something I
was a human right yeah um by the way
David grush has been talking about
non-human biologics yeah I think we
should address that I took a picture I
took a picture of one
maybe we could help David brush with his
terminology a little bit here because
yeah non-human biologics is such a broad
term
what would we what would we call this if
you had three words to describe what you
uh just described to us as your prime
example of undeniable proof that we're
not alone
I would say presumptively
extraterrestrial biology biology that is
most easily explained by a separate Tree
of Life period the end yeah yeah yeah
would that be not not DNA it had some
other self-replicating well let's put it
this way I'm okay with even if it has
DNA but what I I'm going to become very
suspicious if the DNA code is the same
one that terrestrial biology has I would
I would be interested in seeing a
radically different DNA code coupled
with you know if it's built of cells
which is likely
um coupled with a cellular profile that
is radically distinct probably it would
have organelles those organelles would
probably not be either chloroplasts or
mitochondria so anyway DNA is a
possibility
um
what if we what if we went back to like
say you know Precambrian green blue
algae and found a gene Drive in or in
Ginkgo Balboa one of these ancient
species
um would you think that a gene a gene
like inserted you know information
inside the DNA well yeah I think look as
long as we're opening up the you know I
keep a list in my own mind of things
that would tell me that the fundamentals
of what I believe are wrong if I found
for example
a Bible verse from any terrestrial Bible
inscribed in the information molecules
inside of a creature that I could be
confident was a natural creature and not
something that had been tinkered and had
this Bible verse installed I would have
to rethink my epistemology I just simply
would right yeah
um do you know uh Paul Davies proposal
for a second Genesis on Earth this is
his proposal that didn't have to be DNA
it could have been some other
self-replicating molecule system and if
we found that on Earth it'd be a second
Genesis so in a way it's looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence but
terrestrial intelligence as a second
start and it would be you know billions
of years old or something no one's found
this but that would be a reasonable test
so I think this is this is a at some
level this is the heart of the matter
that we are going to end up focusing on
here which is there are many
possibilities and the ability to exclude
possibilities is fundamental to clear
thought but the ease with which one
dismisses a true possibility because it
is initially unlikely or because the
evidence that uh that supports it does
not meet the
um the intuitive threshold of being
extraordinary enough whatever the case
may be it's very easy to throw out a
correct explanation uh because at the
moment you check in on it it's not
supported by the right stuff
so really uh you know all three of us
are going to embrace the idea that
skepticism is fundamental
but the idea that skepticism of what
sometimes you need to be skeptical of
the published literature we've just seen
that with covid and
um that's a very uncomfortable place to
find yourself because once you realize
that the published literature can't be
trusted now you're in a world of
potentially very low quality evidence
um
you know which is not a good place to
try to make sense of the world
yeah I was just talking to Avi lobes
since I'm on the Galileo project and he
has a big profile in New York Times a
magazine about him
that just came out this week and uh he
said they interviewed him for hours and
hours and hours and then after that the
fact Checkers call them and you know
like did you say this here's your exact
quote this is what we're going to use he
says they still got half of the story
wrong and he said then I I got to
thinking that I actually said well what
if it's a story about what's happening
in Ukraine and you know how would I know
what's happening in Ukraine I trust the
New York Times or the Wall Street
Journal whatever what if it's as bad as
they can't even get the story about Avi
lobright amnesia
I have to tell you when you read about
events that happen in the paper and
they're completely different than if if
you knew what actually happened in real
life uh and we're connected to anyone in
there and do your own investigation you
often find uh different things than
other people find and that's true about
everything it's kind of this I I call it
I I refer to like Heidegger's philosophy
of just you know what he said and just
disclosure uh with every disclosure this
concealment and with every concealment
there's also disclosure you know so it's
it's like this back and forth thing as
you look through one lens you're um
you're sort of putting on blinders to
other angles
and uh sometimes but um
you know every I I don't know we've had
a discussion about some of this uh the
Roswell thing maybe we could dig into
Roswell for a second
um because so let me make one comment
Jeremy about something you said about
the you know kind of DARPA research
back to Brett's question of what it
would take not just biologics but if
there were technology that was something
like an anti-gravitational propulsion
system and the guys at DARPA look at
this thing go oh my God we no one on
Earth ever thought of this physics and
Engineering or whatever but that was
definitely how would you know that the
guys at DARPA said that rather than the
guy if they actually said it well no I I
this this I don't get there's a there's
a layer of weakness that surrounds
claims so I my trajectory through logic
space has left me very suspicious of
things that are entirely based on pixels
we've gotten very good at arranging
pixels so they can do some very
compelling things and frankly and you
alluded to this up top Michael
the credentials of the people doing the
claiming the fact is there these are
human beings these are human beings who
respond to incentives uh some human
beings are Shameless once the human
being is frightened even one who is
capable of Shame may say things that
they would not otherwise contemplate so
you know the the problem is if DARPA is
the place that they would be likely to
discover some Transcendent new
technological opportunity like
anti-gravity
I don't know what to make if the DARPA
guys say yeah this is anti-gravity and
it has to be extraterrestrial because
we've never thought of this stuff how do
I know that they're not covering
something that they did think of
yeah but then now you get to a a much
harder problem why should we believe
anything the government or corporations
ever tell us about anything this this
unfortunately Michael this is the
question and it's not I don't want it to
be the question I want us to have a
institutional layer that purges us of
things that mislead us into self-harm
but we obviously don't have that we just
went through three years of non-stop
self-harm as a result of authorities who
not only assured us that they knew what
they were talking about but shamed us if
we asked the most basic questions so
yeah I don't I'm not happy to live in a
world where we can't trust these things
but I believe that's the world we live
in
9 out of 10 doctors smoke camels so
yeah
so yeah yeah it's it's yeah
what is properly dealing with people
like
yeah I know the problem with people like
RFK Jr is that some of the stuff he says
is true like big Pharma captured the
regulatory State and sold a lie about
opioids that they're not addictive
that's true they did do that how did
they do that they just bought off the
politicians and The Regulators yep
really
it's like big tobacco well the the
problem is that the more you dig into
the extraordinary things that RFK JR
says that can't possibly be true the
more you find that actually what he says
is at least based on a rational
evaluation of a chain of evidence that
people are largely unaware of yeah
he makes so many claims I mean Paul off
it's been posting a lot of of RFK
Juniors claims and then like he talks
about this study that was done in 1967
here here's the actual study here's the
quotes from it here's the findings and
this is why RFK Jr is wrong about this
particular thing here
go and then you know it's like he
invites him yeah but Paul please respond
Paul offit just tried to distract us
into believing that the problems with
the MRNA vaccines had to do with the
choice of Spike protein as the uh the
antigenic target
um I don't know why he did that I do
know that he is not insulated from
perverse incentives surrounding vaccines
in fact it appears that he has a
conflict of interest he did address the
conflict of interesting he made no money
because he works that cup whatever
organization he works for but he he
doesn't get any of that no no I don't
know
yeah I don't know where his conflict of
interest begin and end what I do know is
that the portrayal which to me is absurd
that that the spike protein is the
source of all the harm I think the spike
protein is the source of some harm
but the idea that the spike protein is
the fundamental problem with the MRNA
vaccines would rescue that platform from
a much more fundamental problem which
will accompany any vaccine you attempt
to create on it
the fact that there is no targeting of
those mrnas so that they can land in any
cell means that every time you attempt
to vaccinate somebody with that
technology you are inviting an
autoimmune attack on the tissue that
happens to pick up the lipid
nanoparticle so
to me Paul offit is no Authority I'm
ready to trust because where I can check
his work it appears to proceed from a
conflict of interest not from a rational
evaluation of the evidence of where the
harm comes I don't know Brad I mean just
everything you just rattle after I have
no idea what you're even talking about
is way out of my field
I'd be happy to explain it it's very
simple actually but there are tons of
people that this is what they do they
study vaccines and so in public health
and so on you know how did they not know
this but that's the question Michael I
mean and honestly this this is this is
the reason for us to to meet and it's
probably the reason for us to move away
from uaps where we agree and it
evidences the fact that we all share the
same values with respect to getting the
stuff right and exerting skepticism
correctly but how did so many people get
the MRNA vaccine platform wrong I can't
answer that question but I can tell you
that they did because
for the following reason
if you look at the description of how
the vaccine is supposed to work the
description given by those who designed
the vaccine itself
it leads you directly to the question of
won't the cells that transcribe this
mRNA message won't they inherently be
attacked by T cells whose function is to
destroy virally infected cells in other
words what causes cells in the human
body to be attacked by T cells is the
evidence that they have been captured by
a virus and that evidence comes in the
following form they are displaying
antigens that you yourself make and they
are displaying foreign antigens that you
do not make any cell that does that is
presumed by the immune system to be
virally infected and it is attacked by
the immune system because killing it off
is how the body overcomes viral disease
so
if the vaccine the so-called vaccine
stayed in your deltoid when they
injected it then the answer is well the
cells that will be attacked by your
immune system are in your arm and you
can afford to lose them once we knew
that the vaccine circulated around the
body it should be clear to anyone who
understands how immunity develops that
this is going to cause an autoimmune
disorder in any tissue that transcribes
it and if that tissue happens to be your
heart it's going to be a devastating
problem so how Paul offit doesn't know
that I think Paul Offutt has to know
that how did the other people who signed
off on this not know it but I don't know
he's not here I don't I don't even know
what you're talking about it's like you
know you float this hypothesis Jeremy
and I are we this is not what we do so I
don't even know how to you know how is
it possible not just Paul off it you
know this is like thousands of
scientists whatever okay either just
delusional or bought off or perfect
perfect so here's what we've got you
can't evaluate what I said nor should
you be able to you're not a biologist
here's what you can know though I have
just staked my reputation on a claim
about how the immune system works and
how the vaccine as described by those
who
designed it should work
if I'm wrong you Michael Shermer are
sitting here and there should be a flood
of biologists ready to explain what I've
got wrong and when that flood of
biologist doesn't show up you should ask
yourself the question why is that
Weinstein is wrong why is nobody
pointing out the reason did you invite
them on your show to talk about it I
mean I it doesn't matter you you can
invite them I'll invite them show me who
knows the answer to the question and I
I'll be happy to talk maybe I'll host
the episode of the Michael Sherman show
with you and whoever I would love that
if you want to if you want to bring all
of it on who's the guy that uh Rogan
wanted to have back on oh Peter Peter
Hotes yeah maybe
you know it's it's yeah okay okay but
nonetheless let's migrate this from the
questions
the natural origin dude I'm curious see
to me that's a completely open I'll
agree with Brett on this that you know
that should have been always on the
table as a reasonable hypo why not it
was never a conspiracy theory that
Chinese intended to kill people with
this virus it was that they [__] up in
human error and they leaked out of a lab
that seems entirely always seemed to me
entirely plausible why did that get shut
down why did that get shut down and now
that we have the evidence of the emails
in which we see that the very people who
told us that it was Preposterous to
imagine it could have come from the lab
privately believed that was more likely
than not right that tells you something
about the degree to which cover-up might
be playing a role in our narrative and
you have to say so again I don't want to
stick on covid here that my point is not
about covet my point is about what you
do in a badly polluted information
environment and
um you know either I just said something
Preposterous about immunity and vaccines
that reveals my ignorance or I didn't
and it seems to me it should be pretty
easy for us to figure out which thing
just happened and to the extent that
what you're going to discover is that
what I said is perfectly reasonable and
any expert in Immunology ought to know
that if you discover that that probably
ought to make you think wait what else
was hiding in plain sight because that
certainly is
another observation I made I watched the
whole three hours of Rogan's podcast
with RFK Jr and you know he he starts
off with the you know you can't really
trust scientific authorities they get it
wrong and you just those things similar
to what you said and then they got
talking about climate change and then
RFK Jr was like oh you know you got to
trust the science the consensus is in
you know the scientists get it right and
they're right about this one and it's
going to be a catastrophe and he's we're
going to sue these these uh oil
companies and for for ruining our
futures like wait a minute I thought you
just said you can't trust the scientific
authorities and that there's no such
thing as scientific consensus so even
he's not consistent about his skepticism
well I mean look
none of us are perfectly consistent and
I don't even think it's conceivable that
you could be that that's part of that's
the whole reason to have this discussion
is even if we at a values level and
believe me I think if RFK Jr we're
sitting here with the three of us
um you would find that values wise he's
perfectly aligned
um the point is the trajectory he has
taken through history has left him
skeptical of different things than you
or me or Jeremy and that is the question
how do those of us who agree that proper
scientific skepticism is the way to
analytical Clarity how do we figure out
how to talk to each other about which
things are in our blind spots I
certainly want to know there's no
question about that
yeah right well again back to the Paul
often example you know where he would
cite something that RFK Jr said about
this study concluding X and then he
presents the study he goes here it is
here's the excerpts from it here's the
the data and so on and it shows the
opposite of that why did you say that
and he you know at the end of his little
columns is a substance column you know
RFK Junior why are you saying that here
is why you're wrong please respond and
then of course you get no response
uh I have never had that experience with
Robert Kennedy Jr and I know him pretty
well and I have pushed him
yeah okay I do know him and uh well
maybe uh yeah well so why does he not
respond does he not like often or is
there some bad blood there or something
I don't really know why well I don't
know I'm not going to speak for him but
I would say my guess would be
from having delved in areas where uh
where Bobby Kennedy and I see things
alike that the information environment
inside the public published literature
is uh so thoroughly compromised that the
art is in figuring out which studies
were correctly done which is not simple
it requires an awful lot of like words
from Advanced field
yeah so yeah okay so since the
replication crisis started around 2010
you know half of all Psych experiments
probably should have never been
published but a lot of medical
experiments probably should have never
been published and some of them are so
complex that it's hard to even honestly
try to replicate them because the even
the people reporting them may be left
out a few of the steps that they did or
the file drawer problem or they did a
little p hacking that was acceptable at
the time and so on so yeah okay so even
the
checkable empirical questions you're
bringing up should be answerable maybe
even that's hard second from the
separate from the political question you
know Mass mandates or vaccine mandates
you know that's a political question not
a scientific one but some of the stuff
you said should be we should be able to
find out yes or no
the stuff about the the protein spikes
or whatever that was I mean that should
it's either true or not right yeah what
I said is either true or not and I'm I'm
looking for the credible Voice who can
explain why it isn't true because I know
that it is true it's not this let's put
it this way there is a highly Advanced
immunobiology that is beyond my
expertise this isn't at that level this
is pretty basic and
um it should be it should be very easy
for somebody to show where I've got it
wrong
um it's not the first time I've talked
about it and I'm not the only person
who's talked about it either uh so don't
don't people write you and go Brett
Brett Brett let me here's the reason why
you're wrong and here's the citation or
something like this I have literally
never seen a credible response to this
claim I've seen attacks all right Eric
I'm gonna find out
let me also say this to you Mike I and I
we we're going to move topics here in a
second but let me say this to you also
as with everything
if I am wrong about this
boy that's not going to be a fun moment
for me but I would much rather get to
the next moment where I start being
right about things again then double
down on an idea I'm incorrect about I
think that is that is where I'm at so if
I'm wrong about this uh uh you know I'm
gonna have to see the evidence that I'm
wrong but I will shift my position okay
um that's just the way it is
all right so
um
I don't want to stick too heavily over
uaps and where we disagree I think that
topic has done a good job of
demonstrating that we are aligned in our
objectives and in that case land in with
this with our skepticism pointed in the
same direction that there's something
about the current UAP story that is not
compelling us that the most likely
explanation is extraterrestrial
either I just want to clarify that I
think I I if if they do have it it's
inside of a container organization where
it's Untouchable by foia because the
foia requests seem to have gone nowhere
so far and finding it so um I don't know
if you go back to the military
industrial complex and the it's the
Manhattan Project you'll find a lot of
organizations where they hid components
of the Manhattan Project which are still
around today and even manage all of our
National Laboratories so they're in a
perfect position currently
um to basically have a a a one-up on all
the science that that's discovered at
our National Labs and also have um
access to a file like this that's
Untouchable by even the Pentagon or foia
requests so if it does exist it's not
inside the government it's inside a
private military industrial complex you
know contractor where it's on top by
foia and I I don't think it's very
likely that Marco Rubio or any of these
guys will have access to that unless
they really dig hard
um
yeah see that's the thing that bothers
me how can we answer the question then
if we can't trust anybody you can't get
even somebody as high up and influential
as Marco Rubio to get to the answer of
the question and you've seen these
videos of of like Clinton and Hillary
and Obama on these comedian late night
talk shows where they ask them you know
can you tell us what happened in Roswell
I'm going to look into this and then you
know nothing ever comes of it you know
maybe they do maybe there's things the
president doesn't know that Congress
doesn't know and when I was researching
my conspiracy book you know I read all
the stuff about the CIA and you know the
CIA they did a lot of pretty nefarious
things over the decades and you know
it's not almost nothing would surprise
me you know this like Project Blue Book
uh or no sorry not project uh project
paper clip
project paper clip is where we uh got
all these Nazi scientists chemists
biologists and physicists to come on our
side before the Russians got him you
know you sort of see the politics behind
that but you know and I was I just
visited the Auschwitz Exhibition at the
Reagan Museum so they sort of show all
this stuff and added pictures of these
Nazis that worked at Auschwitz some of
them ended up coming to America and
living in Ohio working at some company
you know developing biological weapons
or chemical weapons it's like this is
astonishing at the same time we have
these other guys that did the same thing
at the Nuremberg Trial in the dock and
executed for war crimes you know so that
you know governments are not always not
to be trusted they do lie they do cover
stuff up you know project MK Ultra you
know dosing U.S citizens with a mind
altering drugs without their consent or
knowledge it's like you know the the uh
cointel program of spying on the Civil
Rights activists including the MLK
Junior and you know taping his sex in a
hotel room to blackmail him I mean this
is illegal this is astonishing that you
know and yeah trying to induce him to
commit suicide yeah yeah unbelievable so
I get it when people go you can't trust
the government can't trust the CIA yeah
I see why you know so then who should we
believe but you know and and when and
what criteria all right I don't know so
here's what I'm hoping you uh you
gentlemen will will help me with now
let's move to a topic where I know that
we have Fierce disagreements it's also a
topic that is uh
back on people's minds for obvious
reasons but
um the Kennedy assassinations
uh do you guys want to before we get
into a discussion of how to think about
these things do you guys each want to
state where you fall out on the question
of the John F Kennedy and Robert Kennedy
assassinations
um okay you want to go first Jeremy or
should I yeah yeah
um well I mean both of those have been
brought to attention we mentioned RFK Jr
and he's expressed his concerns and
skepticism over his father's
assassination and also his uncles
um I I know I've spent a lot of time in
you know the early days of the internet
researching JFK and have gone back to it
a few times
over the years and I just went back to
it recently this weekend and and uh
found a whole new channel
um called America's untold stories with
this uh
um very interesting new channel and it's
just so much more informations come out
of uh the the research into
um the Kennedy assassination
um I think it's almost undeniable at
this point that Oswald was a CIA asset
had had ties to both the FBI and the CIA
prior to being set up in Dallas at this
Texas School Book Depository building
which was of course owned by
um the guy who started the Civil Air
Patrol which got Oswald into the CIA
through David Ferry and a number of
other individuals who are also connected
with Civil Air Patrol
um
like uh Roscoe white who went to atsugi
with Oswald and then ended up on the
Dallas police force with a bunch of
other corrupt police so the corruption
in Dallas Police the mayor having his uh
you know cabel
um having his his brother uh being one
of the CIA guys that JFK kicked out
alongside Alan Dulles who was later put
in charge of the Warren Commission
investigation into his assassination
um it's pretty clear that they they gave
the foxes the keys to the hen house and
and put the murderers in charge of the
investigation into who committed the
crime
um so uh that's my position on it so is
it fair to summarize is it fair to
summarize your position as Oswald was
involved
yes absolutely
appears to have been yeah there was more
than one shooter I don't believe the
magic bullet theory and uh I think
there's more than multiple Shooters are
the best explanation for all the bullet
holes
um the eyewitness reports uh multiple
suspicious deaths of witnesses uh
including ones that were supposed to
testify uh in the house of elect
committee on assassinations ten years
later when they tried to open a
reinvestigation into this uh this
conspiracy with the CIA and just
numerous people uh ended up whacked
before they could testify before that
committee I think it's just uh it's
overwhelming uh when you dig into it now
especially you know 50 years 60 years
later where we are now with the amount
of research that's been done uh thanks
to the internet and collaboration of
researchers
but I know okay Michael yep well yeah
definitely we have a something a point
of disagreement there yeah I definitely
think uh Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone I
don't think there's any evidence there's
not a convergence of evidence toward any
other one particular person you'll have
to hear something like well the CIA was
involved well yeah exactly who I mean if
if there were enough evidence to put
somebody into at least a grand jury uh
investigation uh would they therefore
vote to take it to trial and there's
never been enough evidence to name
anybody else to do even that and people
have attempted to do this you know
famously Jim Garrison and you know the
the whole Oliver Stone JFK film is based
on Garrison's investigation of Ferry and
so forth and you know he and the jury
came back like in an hour and said nope
there's nothing here this this man is
free and you know these
it has been tried in abstentia as it
were yeah Clay Shaw uh you know the the
BBC hosted a
uh sort of a faux trial of Lee Harvey
Oswald in which Vincent boliosi played
the prosecuting attorney the guy that
prosecuted Manson and Jerry Spence the
famous defense attorney defended Oswald
and the you know it was not a real trial
of course household's dead but you know
as close as they could get the jury came
back in an hour and said nope Oswald is
guilty he acted alone there was no
evidence for anybody else and so on so
there's a lot of this that's so let's
just think about this how to think about
the way I think about it is a
convergence of evidence to one
particular hypothesis being true and a
lack of convergence of evidence to any
other hypothesis there's lots of
anomalies and this is what we call
anomaly hunting any event that's big and
massive it's easy to find lots of
anomaly 911. there's just dozens and
dozens of just weird things that
happened that day and the 911 truthers
they parade these things out but there's
no convergence of evidence of like who
in the Bush Administration would have
done this how would they have done this
exactly how where did they do this and
when and you know and there's just
nothing there for that and I think it's
like that with the JFK thing I mean like
a lot of the anomalies you know how did
how did how did Oswald just one point
like how did Oswald get the job at The
Book Depository building that just
happened to be on the parade route well
Gerald Posner chased that down and
showed that he got the job before the
parade route had to even be been
determined where he was going to go that
was just Randomness and there's a lot of
those things that turn out to be random
or just lies like uh Oliver Stone has
his character in the film and the mayor
there's one last point and then I'll
I'll shut up uh Oliver Stone has his
character I think it was Jack Lemmon
character say Oswald shot Maggie's
drawers when he was in the iron he
couldn't hit the side of a barn door in
fact Posner track down his rivalry
scores he had the second highest score
possible and if you go to Dealey Plaza
which I've been to twice you look out
the The Book Depository building there's
two x's in the road the throat shot in
the head shot there are close I mean
they're like right there it would be
hard to miss in fact and and he was a
good shot anyway so I'll let that go so
do you think that Oswald is the one that
shot General Walker in April of uh 63.
oh yeah totally yeah so why did he miss
the show
he's sitting still from 16 feet away
Walker was in the house the bullet was
deflected by the window frame as I
understand it
yeah yeah but it seems like such an easy
shot you had all that time to line it
was a nut by the way Target 60. do you
look at Oswald's if possible that's
history
he's a nut why would the CIA and hire a
nut job like Oswald well they deal with
uh wouldn't they hire a professional
assassin somebody who knows what they're
doing it depends it depends it doesn't
depend on what his role was if his role
was to take the fall if the idea was
lone gun nut is going to be the
explanation for what would amount let's
put it this way Michael one of two
things happened in Dealey Plaza either
it was
um an assassination
pure and simple or it was a coup right
well those aren't too different
assassination can be part of a coup or
yeah I guess that again Jeremy is that
false dichotomy though it's like it
could has to be these this thing or the
other one or the other so it's it's yeah
I'm not saying I'm not saying that these
are two categories that have to be I'm
saying in this case given what we know
either the person who committed the
murder went on to die shortly thereafter
and therefore did not gain any power
from doing so or the
murder of John F Kennedy resulted in a
shift of power in the direction of
people who uh were in some way meant to
gain power from the event
but Johnson I mean he's a Democrat you
know he's a liberal and and
well Kennedy wasn't about to de-escalate
Vietnam his own brother said no he we
weren't about to pull out our our not
troops but you know police action
whatever they called it uh that you know
that that wasn't going to happen
well the helicopter there's a question
about
the case if let's see these are just
plausible Just So Stories for uh for a
motivation for the assassination but
that's not evidence to convict somebody
that they actually did that they could
have done you know Kennedy said you know
I want to break the CIA into a thousand
pieces famous quote after the Bay of
Pigs when they lied to him you know he
understandably was pissed off and of
course presidents shoot their mouth off
as we know about all sorts of things
that doesn't mean
yeah
pigs like David Atlee Phillips and
Howard hunt and uh Frank Sturgis these
guys hated Kennedy and they were talking
about you know whacking him down in
Florida and New Orleans and stuff the
weekend think about all the people that
hate Trump but no one assassinated Trump
well they had a plot in Chicago what
kind of evidence is that Michael that's
not evidence this is hindsight bias once
Kennedy is shot then you go back in time
go okay let's see who hated him well
lots of people in Trump but and if
somebody assassinated okay now we're
going to go back and find the people
that really hate him let me just make uh
since you mentioned the Magic Bullet so
in my chat here's my book conspiracy in
the chapter on JFK I actually have the
magic so here's the magic bullet theory
in which Kennedy and Connolly are lined
up perfectly and the bullet has to make
a right turn of left turn that is not
how they reced it this is how they were
actually seated the limousine had a jump
seat that was lower and off kilter to
where Kennedy was from uh Connolly so
they were actually perfectly lined up
with the bullet coming from back uh in
The Book Depository straight through the
two of them right through the neck the
next shot uh the first shot missed the
second shot was the next shot the third
shot was the head shot 85 percent of all
ear Witnesses said three shots they
heard three shots and uh and then here
you can see one last point on this
there's the so-called pristine bullet
which was not pristine it was bent it
was you know dented that way now this is
gonna be hard to see in here but if you
look at the bruter film 313 you can find
us online and there's high resolution
versions of it cleaned up and they show
it in super slow motion it's pretty
gruesome scene but the the brain matter
goes up and forward like the shot came
from behind not back into the left like
in the JFK film you know back into the
left that isn't what happened the brain
matter goes forward and up up and you
can see some of it splatter at the
impact point where I think the bullet
hit for the front of the head but I I
see the head go back into the left after
the uh after the shot but but the
initial brain matter goes forward up and
forward you can see it in the photo it
hard to see in that black and white
photo but if you look at the core color
version on YouTube you can see that
people have put arrows to show where the
brain matter is going I think that
there's a whole conspiracy with there to
change the wounds they flew him out of
uh Dallas which the by law if you die in
Dallas uh your autopsy has to be
performed right in the state you uh in
the county that you die in but they
specifically move him to bethesda's
naval hospital where they lose his brain
um multiple things happen to his corpse
uh there's there's very poor
documentation
um all the Parkland hospitals that
describe the wounds on JFK having seen
him in the trauma room one
um their stories are completely
inconsistent with uh with all that
evidence and then the body that gets to
Bethesda
um may not actually be JFK's according
to uh you know some of these researchers
who have found out that JD Tippett the
police officer who Oswald supposedly
shot on his uh you know away from the
school Book Depository to the theater
um JD Tippett was uh you know this
Dallas police officer who looked just
like JFK used they used to get teased by
the other officers uh that they used to
call him Jack and um and there's a
belief that he was used as the body
double because the way that he was
apparently shot
um you know at point-blank range right
from in the exact way that JFK's head
wounds were so if they switched the body
they could have you know shown the
coronary uh that you know he was uh he
was an eyewitness way there was an
eyewitness
but there was an eyewitness that saw
Oswald shoot tip it so there's another
one said there was two people there and
the the description of the people that
ran away did not match uh Oswald's
description yeah so
I want to just point out the weakness in
your position Michael and it's not that
this inherently makes you wrong but it's
something I think you have to
acknowledge
the problem with conspiracy is that it
upends Occam's razor
when there is a conspiracy what we have
is inherently an attempt to make some
set of facts align to point to an
explanation that is not true
that is the nature of a conspiracy right
and so what you are pointing to Michael
is a set of facts that admittedly points
to an explanation that we've all been
told is true and some of us disbelieve
it's not surprising that you would be
able to put together that chain of
evidence the question is is that chain
of evidence actually more robust than an
alternative analysis that looks at all
of these pieces and attempts in other
words Occam's razor is a property of the
universe it ought to be true when you
have all of the evidence we never have
all of the evidence and so what we are
left with is a question of what is the
correct frame what is the sum total of
facts that we are actually trying to
account for and that's that's the reason
that people who you know like all of us
believe in Occam's razor but we end up
at different conclusions the question is
what set of facts did we hold ourselves
responsible for
um for uh reconciling and what set of
facts did we feel entitled to exclude
and I think there's something buried in
your point about anomalies
because you're absolutely right that in
any sort of complex especially a chaotic
environment like an assassination there
are going to be coincidences anomalies
that mean nothing those things are going
to exist but there is also some
threshold some number of anomalies that
is too many to be accounted for by the
uh the circumstances and so we have to
we have to both be good at not leaping
to conclusions because we see one or two
anomalies but at the point that there
are too many anomalies failing to jump
is an equally severe problem yeah okay
that's a fair point part of the problem
though is is because if it's a big event
people are very interested in chasing
down all those anomalies if it was the
mayor of Dallas that was assassinated in
Delhi Plaza would we be having this
conversation with anybody care would
there be any books movies no no one
would care all those anomalies would not
even appear on the radar because no one
would be looking for them but you know
like so the I talked about one of these
do you know who Louis Steven vit is
w-i-t-t Louisville aka the umbrella man
so out there on the grass is on a clear
sunny day with no forecast of rain as a
guy with an umbrella what was this guy
doing there oh my God this you know that
maybe this umbrella was an actual weapon
and so I actually picture have a picture
of this umbrella that could be used as a
gun uh because it's not real investment
it's a real CIA invention by the way
yeah it's a real invention yeah for sure
yeah so finally like a decade later he
finally comes out into the clear and
actually Earl Morris did a short film
for the New York Times on on the
umbrella man until and told this whole
story and his story was that the
umbrella was a sign of protest against
Kennedy because
Kennedy's Father Joseph was kind of
friendly toward the Nazis was uh you
know friendly toward appeasing the Nazis
and when Neville Chamberlain gets off
the plane after meeting with hair Hitler
who promised he wouldn't take any more
territory and he's got his umbrella and
he's got the piece of paper you know
look Hitler's signed he promised and so
the umbrella became a protest against
the Kennedy family for being appeasers
and he felt this Louis vuit that JFK
himself was an appeaser and therefore he
was against him and he was out there
protest so all of that none of that
would have happened again
instead of JFK that it was David Morales
and that he was there to tell Kennedy
that they were going to kill him for not
supplying air support for the Bay of
Pigs invasion and that was the the cia's
way of letting Kennedy know
I think the the
umbrella is the perfect demonstration of
both your point Michael and my point
here
as far as I know the umbrella is a red
herring in conspiracy land but it does
turn out to have a mundane explanation
although in trying to sort out what may
have taken place that day seeing a
person anomalously holding an umbrella I
mean it is an anomaly it's just an
anomaly that points to a protest rather
than a reaction to the weather
so it's meaningless now maybe it's not
meaningless but as far as I know the
most parsimonious explanation for that
one is that it's not a an important
Factor right Abraham it is hardly
say that again do you know who Abraham
Bolden was
no no go ahead so Abraham Bolden was the
first black uh Secret Service security
guard and he was in Chicago that's right
right with uh basically exposed this
whole plot in Chicago
um that was supposedly happened a week
before uh or or shortly before uh the
Dallas assassination that there was a
Chicago JFK plot to to kill Kennedy and
he was jailed and put in um
and put in uh prison and and prevented
from testifying about this and uh it's
just one of those another interesting
anomalies but that that's that's a
pretty big one on my radar as far as you
know it was their plot within you know
at least some somewhere within the
government uh the the mob mainly uh the
mob connections between Chicago and
Dallas
um that are talked about in some of the
investigations with you know Johnny
roselli
um seeing giancana who hated the RFK and
uh and and the Kennedys and um you know
these guys wanted the Kennedys out and
they wanted to get back into Cuba
because you know Castro came in and
kicked out all the casinos he outlawed
gambling there and so they were they
allowed they lost a like it's like
losing lot the city of Las Vegas for
them they're like there's tons of money
that we're not making anymore
um so they were uh they were on the side
of the CIA and and working with uh a lot
of these factors
um and then you get into the the the the
oil men that hated Kennedy for the oil
depletion allowance that the uh Harold
bird and and uh Clint Murchison
supposedly had this meeting where they
you know we're talking about a bunch of
you know anti-kennedy people there so
there's there's all these avenues that
seems like oh that this just shouldn't
be investigated and and and looked into
and it's too big of a conspiracy and now
you're involving you know Ruth Payne who
you know brought the oswalds from New
Orleans to Dallas and gave them a home
uh supposedly she was this real nice
lady who was just wanted to help people
but there's no evidence of her helping
anyone but the oswalds moved to to
Dallas and get jobs there and then it
turns out her sister uh worked for the
CIA and all these other connections that
came out later with Ruth Payne
um documents came out later that um
gotta got out of the archives and stuff
and then there's still like 5 000
documents or something that the
government won't release related to the
JFK assassination uh for seven years
later someone does that tell you like
what could possibly
on that one I I'm pretty sure I know uh
it's probably something embarrassing
that the CAA was up to with some foreign
country that is now one of our allies
you know because they did do a lot of
that kind of stuff right so it's hard
it's hard to imagine though Mike
it's hard to imagine this many years
later even if this was something
embarrassing against uh an important
Ally the people involved are
overwhelmingly dead already
um yeah so the point is uh Amir culpa in
which the American public could finally
uh rest easy that no coup took place in
1963 would be worth it and yet it
doesn't happen well we're done okay but
almost all the documents have been
released like one percent well sure but
but you would expect the only way the
only way to get those of us who see the
number of anomalies as too high to be
credibly explained by Oswald acting
alone
is complete transparency and if you're
like well we'll release 98 percent
oh I say release them all I'm completely
agreement with you there now so what
we're talking about here bigger picture
signal detection problem what you know
there are conspiracies they do happen uh
foreign leaders have been assassinated
we just saw uh we just saw Putin
assassinate Prego Jean very likely
um and it's it's kind of counter to my
I've been tweeting uh since the book
came out you know never a tribute to
malice what can be explained by
incompetence or chance and then I
reversed it in the case of Putin never
attribute to chance what could be
explained by malice because of his
history right so the question is did it
how many elements would have to come
together
for the conspiracy to to be pulled off
and so one of the criteria I use present
the book is you know we don't know for
sure you're right I mean no one has all
the information the anomalies do matter
and they put the more they pile up the
more interesting the story gets but in
fact a lot too many of those anomalies
actually points to something probably
more mundane in as much as we know how
real conspiracies work it's hard to get
people to be at the right place at the
right time to be incompetent to keep
their mouth shut
and to not chicken out not change their
mind and not squeal they're not you know
pillow talk with a lover and say oh you
know what I was I was there at 9 11. I
it's part of it or I know my best friend
was you know you know nothing you know
that that kind of thing happens all the
time Watergate is a classic example you
know the leader of the Free World can't
even have his top G Min pull off a
break-in I mean you know just G Gordon
Lydia himself says you know these people
are just incompetent they can't keep
their mouth shut and there's an idea
that those guys
put Nixon on the hot plate too because
uh they were involved oh yeah because
those Watergate burglars it was Sturgis
it was how eight Howard hunt
um it was guys that were accused of
being connected to JFK assassination I
know Frank Sturgis has been accused of
being one of the three tramps that were
arrested in Dealey Plaza yeah oh that
three they arrested these guys and then
didn't never booked them never took
their names and then just let them go or
so someone went and let them go from the
police station and then destroyed all
the records of them getting arrested but
the news photographer took their
pictures so there was that record at
least and uh that was that was pretty
curious
um that those guys so I I I do find the
connections uh the apparent connections
between the JFK assassination and uh
Watergate to be another anomaly that uh
causes me to worry that something more
than Oswald acting alone happened in
Dealey Plaza but well then I want to go
after this
where Nixon was talking about the whole
day of pigs thing
right
um but I wanna I wanna drill down on
this issue you raised because I hear it
all the time Michael about the question
of how hard it is to get people to stay
quiet
and there are two points that I think
need to be made in response
it is hard but not impossible to get
people to stay quiet uh things like the
Manhattan Project uh reveal that you can
have a very large project with very high
levels of secrecy but
I don't even think that's the The
crucial failure in in that point The
crucial failure is it's much easier to
get people to stay quiet if you're
willing to kill people who don't stay
quiet
well Putin does that I guess sure but I
guess I guess the point is logically
speaking analytical is not I think yeah
I think you have to say yeah under
ordinary circumstances a large
conspiracy would tend to out itself
because somebody would talk and it would
emerge on the other hand we do have a
pattern of uh
conspicuous failure to thrive of
Witnesses in the JFK assassination case
and that once you have an example would
be Antonio
have you ever heard of Antonio vesiana
he was talking to Bill O'Reilly and then
he got shot at three times and then he
the next time they tried to interview
him he's like not talking not going to
talk about this at all
um I don't know about that story okay so
here's a counter example so you know
with Wikileaks we have millions of
classified documents leaked against the
government's wishes nothing in there
about JFK make moon landing 911 inside
job you would expect there must be some
paper trail of who paid who what would
be leaked out but there was nothing
no I think I think Jeremy's point from
earlier is the Salient one which is that
to the extent that you are dealing with
competent conspirators that organizing
you know the way terrorists use cells in
order to keep uh from being destroyed by
a mole so that cells are insulated from
each other so that one cell doesn't
reveal another
that that would be a rational way of
compartmentalizing information so that
the revelation of one conspiracy didn't
reveal all the others and uh you know in
the case of an assassination you're
dealing with people who are willing to
kill so are they more willing to kill
presidents than they are witnesses that
doesn't make any sense
again I'm not arguing
the shooters
the shooters don't even know this
they're the shooters or what they're
what they're doing you know they're
they're given wrong information and told
wrong and they don't even know who's got
the bullets a lot of times that's true
they are siled like the Manhattan
Project not very many people knew
everything that was going on right yeah
but yeah so so all I would say again my
interest here is not in the JFK
assassination it's not in covid it's not
in uaps it's in grappling with the
question of how one rationally deals
with an a set of circumstances that can
be explained by a narrative with which
we are presented and could be explained
by collusion that would frame that
narrative so that it would be salable
in the case I believe in the case of
collusion where killing is one of the
allegations one has to back off their
skepticism uh on the basis that somebody
would have talked
because if the pattern was that people
who talked got offed and people who
realized that they shouldn't talk
remained alive you would get the false
appearance that nobody was talking sure
you get an omerto rule like in the mafia
certainly okay two points uh one as a
very Pious man dies and goes to heaven
and God says
son you've been a very Pious man I will
grant you one wish I'll answer any
question you want and he goes I want to
know who really shot JFK and God says
Lee Harvey Oswald acting alone with his
carcana rifle and the guy goes this goes
even higher than I thought it's a good
joke I like it the serious Point here's
how I addressed that issue Brett is that
I use kind of a Bayesian reasoning
approach starting with cromwell's rule
Oliver Cromwell famously said I beseech
you in the bowels of Christ you might be
mistaken never assign a zero or one to
any hypothesis always somewhere between
1 and 99 say so yes any of these things
are possible so you know the so in terms
of conspiracy the way I think about it
is you know the more people that would
have to be involved the more elements
that would have to come together at just
the right time without incompetence or
mistakes or chance or Randomness
interfering with the whole how many
steps have to you know come together
just the right place the less likely the
theory is to be true it's not it could
be it could be everybody kept their
mouth shut it could be all 27 people
were at the right place at the right
time you know they moved the brain they
planted the bullet they doctored the
autopsy they use the body double but you
know and then they had the Ruth Payne
and she got Oswald the job you know at
some point though there's just so many
elements I would say my probability is
low I think you've got the logic Wrong
by your own standard
you tell me if I've got this incorrect
okay what you just said what you just
said The more things that have to come
together just so the less likely it is
to be the explanation I believe that
that forces you to embrace the idea that
the moon landing was faked because the
number of things that had to come
together to put people on the moon is
much greater than the number of things
that had to come together to make it
look like we put people on that side I
don't know you'd have to it's easier to
fake that in the studio for sure totally
2001 was a good movie that was some
compelling space stuff collimated light
that's the biggest problem there so
I have a whole chapter in my book on the
assassination of Franz Ferdinand that
triggered the first world war because
that was probably the deadliest
conspiracy in history and it really was
a conspiracy you know this this group of
uh Serbian nationalists you know we're
not happy about Austrian politics and
and so forth and Franz ferdinand's The
Heir Apparent he's going to come to the
Sarajevo for this ceremony and blah blah
blah he's in a convertible and they
plotted to kill him and they had like
seven different guys and they each had
to go to a different house to get the
weapon different weapons they're going
to position them on the Parade route and
so and none of it went according to plan
and and they still managed to
assassinate him just by Chance the you
know the the guy pulls the the pin on
the hangar name he tosses it at just the
right time when the convertible cars
coming by but slightly missed bounce off
the the trunk of the car that he was
supposed to hit goes under the car
behind him that car explodes and the
people are injured and the car dashes
off and then they go to he gives a
speech in which he kind of upgrades the
public for treating him so badly and
then they go back to the hospital to
check on the people that were injured
and they go back on the parade route
backwards on the Parade route and then
the car makes a wrong turn on this
pelquez road where the Assassin was
still sitting there and the car had no
reverse so the driver puts it in neutral
and kind of backs up slowly and there is
a princess one of the Assassins standing
right there with his gun and there's
Franz ferdin sitting right there in
front of Bam Bam dead and you know
totally unexpected totally random and I
use this as an example is that's how
these things usually go yeah a lot of
oil oiled machine but just you know
Randomness yeah but but what happened in
Dallas doesn't look to me like a
well-oiled machine it looks to me like a
story that's very like the one you just
told the the failure of caskets to match
the the bullet showing up on the
stretcher this looks like something
where
look I don't know what it looks like but
I will say if it was a conspiracy
and the people conspiring understood how
complex what they were trying to pull
off was they would have had some sort of
how do we how do we take care of loose
ends that emerge in the middle of this
chaotic event how do we take care of
things we didn't anticipate
this is what that would look like and it
would look imperfect and it would cause
people like me and I think Jeremy to
look at the evidence and say actually
it's yes we see the picture that you see
but if we look at a broader swath of the
evidence what it actually looks like is
that that picture is being deliberately
created inside a much richer story
and I would add to that
that where you stop analyzing evidence
is crucial and in the case of the JFK
assassination I think the two most
important pieces of evidence are the Lee
Harvey Oswald assassination and the
Bobby Kennedy assassination
that if this was a coup
in which Lee Harvey Oswald was a patsy
then you would have to have those two
loose ends tied up because uh lihari
Oswald
was in a position to reveal that
something larger happened that day yes
and Bobby Kennedy was in a position to
pick up where John F Kennedy left off
Oswald screams out I'm I'm just a patsy
right so so he was he he probably would
have talked
um the Loose Ends that you have to cover
up too like uh how did Oswald get from
the school Book Depository building
um to where he shot JD tip it in that
amount of time so the time thing is is
another issue that investigators have
struggled with establishing and they've
had to delay the shooting by you know 19
minutes to make give Oswald enough time
to even get there to do the shooting and
um
it comes out eight days after
um Ruth Payne gives a a book that was
supposedly from Oswald's possession
gives it to the Secret Service and
inside that they find the letter that he
wrote to Marina supposedly the night he
went to go shoot uh Walker now the cops
in the FBI had already you know been
through his entire bookcase and and
searched it thoroughly but then this
note shows up
um you have things like this that look
like a nom look like planted evidence
literally the chain of um the CIA
putting these pieces together to give
you this one-sided picture of what
happened
and yeah you can't use Occam's razor on
something like that because you have an
powerful agency actively working to Fort
those efforts every step of the way
well here I'd recommend Gerald posner's
book case closed about uh Lee Harvey
Oswald in his whole history and tracks
all those things you just mentioned and
then the definitive book uh
um but what is it history stored I think
it is
um this is
um shoot I just had mentioned him before
um hang on for a second it's uh
I like John Newman's book Oswald
Vincent baliosi's book yeah it's uh 1600
Pages he deals with he he goes with like
nonsense
but there's people like you that say
what about this anomaly what about this
there's hundreds of these anomalies when
you look closely so Jeremy you
recommended a book but I didn't hear
what it was oh that's a book uh called
uh Oswald in the CIA by John Newman
um but also uh why don't we go into we
can we can maybe go into um oh Mount Mac
Wallace is another interesting guy to
investigate in the JFK Saga he was
apparently lbj's uh assassin
and a member of Skull and Bones uh next
to George H.W bush who is linked to the
assassination through um
George de morningshield you know I'm
surprised that Michael's not already you
know real familiar with a lot of these
topics researching the JFK assassination
George demorenshield was a was a big
name uh he of course you know Sean
himself in the back of the head uh
before he could finish testifying to the
uh house select committee on
assassinations and uh wrote a letter to
George H.W bush had his name you know
was had Bush's name and his uh directory
of uh contacts and wrote a letter to him
you know shortly before he died and then
it's interesting that bush gets put in
charge of the CIA in 74 just in time for
the house select committee on
assassinations that they want to put
someone who's outside the agency to
clean it up and get to the bottom of
this JFK stuff so they put bush in
charge and it turns out you know that
that uh you know bushes had
um
he his oil company was called Zapata oil
um and he ran this oil company that he
got from his father and they had the
first uh offshore oil rigs in the in the
Caribbean Sea and they were used as
staging platforms for the Bay of Pigs
operation uh which was codenamed
Operation Zapata which is Bush's company
so you have
um you know Bush tied into these this
group of uh you know CIA anti-castro
Cubans that you know hated Kennedy
um and then all these people were in
Dallas Bush was in Dallas uh Nixon was
in Dallas and Ford you know three future
presidents all there at the same time
and then Ford was of course you know on
the uh I think he was head of either the
house select committee or one of these
investigations where where Ford was on
the uh Warren Warren Commission the
Warren Commission yeah he was on the
Warren Commission so you know he's
rewarded for you know
the Warren Commission because of Earl
Warren the Supreme Court Justice I mean
you think they're all in on this
uh I think that that Dulles definitely
staged that whole thing and and control
and pulled a lot of the strings so that
you know Earl Warren was blind to it the
same way that I think that you know
other commissions and investigations uh
have been run into um some of these
official events you look at the yeah
they appoint people in charge who who uh
who may not be uh the actual ring
leaders of a conspiracy but uh they're
definitely willing to go along with um
The Narrative on a lot of things often
so I don't know Earl Warren is uh is is
definitely suspect but the Warren
Commission I I definitely uh I
definitely think that it was a bias and
um
unproductive investigation as far as you
know identifying you know potential
suspects other potential suspects
man that's a lot of dot connecting there
well but but Michael uh CAA and Bush and
Ford and uh on and on all of them I mean
really they're all right I don't think
you I don't think you heard it I don't
think
the thoughts on them I know I know
too many dots it depends it sounds to me
Michael like you are assuming that the
fact of those dots being on the map
necessarily leads to the assumption that
they were all in on it and I don't hear
that assumption being made I think the
point is those things are anomalies
you know could it be a coincidence that
uh George H.W bush was in Dallas of
course
it could it be a coincidence in light of
the fact that he seems to be the only
adult American who doesn't remember
where he was
um that's a weird fact
um in his Memoirs he was meeting with
the guy named Al Ulmer his uh his
Barbara Bush's Memoir she admits that
they're that week they were meeting with
a guy named Almer and um
Al olmer was actually a a expert in coup
d'etats
uh so why was you know the cia's closet
CIA agent meeting with an expert in coup
d'etaz the week before he goes to Dallas
um it's just a lot a lot of coincidence
I mean coup d'etat President Johnson he
just extended whatever Kennedy was doing
Civil Rights Acts and the so on all the
policies he instituted they were just
pretty much a continuation and then
after Johnson is Nixon and I mean what
coup d'etat
no you you you you uh
earlier you cite the fact that Kennedy
said he was going to break the CIA into
a thousand people well he just was
complaining they lied to me those well
no no but you you are now extrapolating
beyond what we know
to the extent that what took place after
Kennedy's assassination was that nobody
broke the CIA into a thousand pieces it
is possible it one rational explanation
is that the CIA in an act of
self-preservation assassinated a
president and caused that piece of the
agenda to change that's one possibility
that's I'm not saying that story
happened I'm not saying there's evidence
for it but I'm saying it is not
preposterous
that the desired policy change did occur
and that we are now witness to it
because the CIA still exists
right but but presidents say stuff like
this all the time RFK Jr said if he gets
elected president he's going to close
all 900 military bases around the world
no he's not this is not going to happen
right now the military industrial Congo
I'm not gonna let this happen just in
the same way that Obama said you know if
I get elected I'm going to close gitmo
and I'm going to pull the troops out and
and then so here's my concession to a
conspiracy theory when you get elected
president they take you in the back room
and they go okay here's what's actually
going on in the world oh we can't I
can't pull the troops up no of course
you can't do that I can't close it but
now you can't close it like this as well
all right but I said every I told
everybody I would yeah don't worry about
that I mean I think that's just kind of
real politics right it's just kind of
the dirty business of how things
actually operating of course now um did
you guys want to discuss MK Ultra did I
yes
heard of a guy named Dr William J Bryan
before
yes uh I must have come across that name
in the in the book on MK Ultra
I don't think I know the name because
you mentioned you read the book on MK
you didn't find like the meat and
potatoes there and um I'm surprised
William J Bryan
he was a very interesting guy he
pioneered the the a lot of the work on
hypnosis and um he's allegedly yeah yeah
okay right Brian is allegedly the doctor
that programmed Sirhan Sirhan in fact he
bragged uh about being responsible for
that at one point in his life uh that he
had been the MK Ultra doctor that had
hypnotized Sirhan Sirhan
um to you know fire it at RFK RFK Must
Die
um and the the so this is uh yeah this
is interesting that the CIA was doing
some you know very risque
um things with mind control and and then
I I guess this
somehow like these these overlapping
connections somehow this guy ends up
um I don't know if it's William J Bryan
but um one of these guys ends up being
uh the psychologist who gives um Jack
Ruby his mental evaluation for
um is an MK Ultra doctor so it's kind of
like it's interesting how that they they
have their doctors they have their um
they have people in the police
department even
um apparently according to uh
foreign
investigations that were done there was
a mole in the police force in um the Los
Angeles police force this guy Pina
and um Manuel Pina was basically it was
a CIA agent and he was in charge of the
investigation into rfk's murder for the
LAPD
and they
um
they're the ones that lost the that
panel with the extra bullet holes that
are in the log by the FBI so there's
extra bullet holes extra gunshots
um
you got the guy who followed and walked
uh RFK into the kitchen
who's testified
um
about him you know he's come out and he
was actually at uh Sirhan sirhan's
parole hearing trying to get him free
because he doesn't believe that Sirhan
Sirhan fired the shot that actually
killed RFK
he thinks that it was the security guard
a thing Eugene sees who had followed him
into the pantry and that you know it was
the investigators did a whole
investigation of him and they concluded
that there wasn't enough evidence to to
try him so so hold on Michael though
again if there was a conspiracy to kill
RFK then you have to build into that
model that it would include enough
um
Firepower to use the wrong analogy to
disrupt a proper investigation which
would then result in difficult to
explain anomalies like a door frame that
appears to contain the evidence that
there were more bullets than Sirhan had
in his gun that door frame disappearing
mysteriously under the control of the
LAPD I mean just think for a moment how
hard is it to lose a door frame I can
imagine misfiling it but I can't imagine
oh my God the door frame is gone and it
doesn't occur to somebody that there's
an extra door frame leaning up somewhere
right it's hard to imagine and so you
would expect an anomaly like that
because if there is a door frame that
indicates that there are more bullets
than there were I believe Sirhan
sirhan's gun contained eight Chambers
um if there was a door frame that
suggested more than eight bullets were
fired then that would in and of itself
establish that there must be some other
shooter that is being sought
so it would have to disappear and that
would result in a persistent anomaly
that
um 50 plus years later we would still be
talking about right
so so I guess the point is Michael I
hear you repeatedly saying but there was
an investigation and here's the The
Logical path that that investigation
concluded is the most parsimonious
explanation for the assassination and
the allegation that there may have been
collusion beyond that assumes an
explanation like the one you present and
then says but that if we zoom out and we
look at a larger uh uh collection of
evidence actually it's not the most
parsimonious explanation anymore
so it's built in
Maybe
you know gentlemen I mean again you're
just it's the hindsight bias and you're
just going okay I mean it's like if
Trump got shot people would be going
okay all right who could have been
involved well you better check out
Stormy Daniels and Cohen and all the
people that uh that hated him and would
have wanted him dead and so on but that
hasn't happened so we don't care about
whatever they're doing so in hindsight
we look back and go like any something's
weird something's off here maybe and you
know the proportionality bias we want
big important people that die to have
big important causes of their death you
know the Nazi Holocaust the Holocaust
worst thing that ever happened the Nazis
worst political regime in history
there's a balance there you know
Princess Diana cause of death you know
drunk driving speeding no seatbelt yeah
but princesses can't die the way you
know regular people died there must have
been you know the MK Ultra sorry the MI6
or the you know the royal family or the
Arabs you know somebody had to be behind
this same thing with JFK RFK MLK also
conspiracy theories about his
assassination yeah and anybody that's
big and important like that 911 just
you're telling me 19 guys with box
cutters Bulldog nylon impossible had to
be operatives inside the Bush
Administration and then you go down that
rabbit hole well so wait let's go to the
MLK one because I think actually it's
quite telling
in the MLK case you have again a
mainstream narrative an investigation
that concludes a mainstream narrative
but you also and I'm going to be quickly
out of my depth here maybe one or the
other of you knows the information that
I don't but in a Civil Trial
it was actually established not Beyond
Reasonable Doubt but by a preponderance
of the evidence that the there was
governmental involvement in the
assassination of RFK I mean not RFK yeah
yeah
um yeah so what that tells you
what that tells you is it tells you
where we are in logical space that there
is a tension between in this case it's a
question of thresholds of evidence
the evidence gets above the threshold of
a preponderance but not to the level of
satisfying an investigation that leans
more towards Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
right just as we were with with OJ
so that tells you in logical space that
it this is a question of thresholds of
evidence
and I would argue that in all of these
cases thresholds of evidence and burdens
of proof are really the key things that
one has to track in order to
analytically be consistent and to follow
the evidence where it leads
right so amazing reasoning preponderance
of evidence is 50 plus a feather just
we're just above it and and the reason
the criminal court system has a higher
standard of evidence is because of
um of Blackwell's ratio ten to one
better ten guilty people go free than
that one innocent person be convicted
therefore we're gonna have a much higher
standard Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and
so on and and it again if you put one of
these people on trial you know MLK had
you know hundreds of death threats I
don't know every year month or whatever
I mean just lots of people wanted him
dead and I wrote to them and only commit
suicide right yes yes exactly right
exactly to clarify that for the audience
I'm not sure they heard you Jeremy
um the FBI wrote to MLK and attempted to
induce him to kill himself on the basis
that he would be embarrassed uh by
evidence they would reveal of his
infidelity I believe if he did not
comply I mean one of the reasons we we
know so much about MLK's life is because
the FBI taped his life they taped all
his phone calls for years so we know who
said what to win and when they
orchestrated this March or that protest
we know the details thanks to the FBI
and yeah it's astonishing so you know
I'll grant you that uh you know the
cointel pro it wasn't just MLK I mean
they infiltrated the Native American
civil rights groups and feminist groups
and so on their stories about there were
more uh FBI agents at these protest
meetings than there were protesters
the joke was you could tell because they
had the the hippie clothes but they were
wearing wingtips something like I don't
know if that's actually true but uh but
yeah so of course they could have done
it I mean the FBI could have been
involved in the assassination of them I
mean certainly Hoover hated him and and
truly believed apparently that not just
MLK but most of these civil rights
leaders were a real threat to American
democracy and peace and stability and so
on so sure so okay but you know again
the question is what to conclude from
these things which raised co-intel Pro
you've raised MK Ultra in the case of MK
Ultra I believe there are connections
not only to Sirhan Sirhan
but to Ted Kaczynski
micro and maybe even maybe am I right
that Manson is also yeah there's a book
there's a book I forget to name it I
just read it two years ago so I forget
the name but about the connection
between Manson and uh the MK Ultra
program and Ted Kaczynski as well but it
was disappointing at the end he never
got a Smoking Gun it's a journalist okay
but he tracked the story for like 30
years he thought I'm really gonna get
this and he's you know he really Dove
deep into it at the end so I just just
could get the Smoking Gun okay so no
smoking gun but at the very least it is
conspicuous that you have three
notorious murderers who appear to have a
connection to a CIA program of Mind
Control involving hallucinogens
yeah it's well one of the curious things
is how Manson got uh his followers to
actually commit the murders he wasn't
even there
uh and so uh the theory is that he used
mind control techniques and drugs you
know and sex and power and so on to get
these uh women in Tex Watson to to to
commit the murders that's that's the
theory not implausible I mean you know
it is weird he was able to do that but
cult leaders are able to get followers
to do all kinds of crazy things okay you
know witness Jonestown or the Heaven's
Gate or any of these people how about
again my my point here isn't about
Manson or Kaczynski uh or Sirhan Sirhan
or JFK MLK
it's about how Mark David Chapman shoots
uh John Lennon and then starts reading
The Catcher in the Rye just you know
there's no logic almost like he's
participating in in the construction of
a narrative
um but let's put it this way
I think one of the things that is very
frustrating if one tries to be
analytically consistent and rigorous in
this space is that we get dismissed on
the basis that that is a conspiracy
theory and therefore it is wrong
when MK Ultra is a conspiracy obviously
involving a CIA which wishes to use mind
control does it end at the point that
the program is revealed and formally put
to bed
I don't know but no unfortunately in
that case most of the records were
destroyed oh what a shame this came out
in in the Frank Olson case you know
Frank Olson was the ca operative who
killed himself or was pushed or
something weird in a New York high-rise
after he was dosed with LSD and the
government under Ford Administration
paid the family uh I think 750 000 to
just basically let's say go away and
let's put an end of the story yeah it's
weird so can't we agree that the you
know the folks who do not deserve a
place in the conversation are the people
who reflexively dismiss something
because it is a so-called conspiracy
theory oh for sure one of the things I
tried to do in my book is to get rid of
that pejorative to call something a
conspiracy theory means it's [__] no
there are conspiracies all over the
place all the time they happen and
everybody knows that so having a theory
that one of them might be going on is
completely legitimate of course not not
only that but we know there is debate
over the meaning of
um the memo but the CIA
introduces this term as a mechanism for
getting rid of hypotheses about the
assassination of John F Kennedy that's
true yes and so the fact that it became
a pejorative isn't even organic in
itself I know exactly yeah so so anyway
look I think this is being this is super
productive we've gotten to a place where
we recognize that in all of these cases
so far there is at least something to be
rationally discussed there is no side
that is so Preposterous that it is
dismissable out of hand in each case
there is a frustrated lack of a clear
evidentiary boundary that tells us one
way or the other which what what is most
parsimonious
um and that rational people can have
such a discussion
um
and can reach different conclusions that
that's that's big progress as far as I'm
concerned uh ditto I think so too so the
question then becomes how can we drill
down and get an answer maybe we can't
always get an answer that's certainly
always on the table uh but like to your
the previous point about vaccines you
know somebody surely knows the answer to
this okay let's get let's talk to that
person and so if we can't talk about it
you know then where are we nowhere we we
have to talk about it agreed so I wonder
if we ought not push our luck and go
even farther in the direction of uh
ideas that are not discussed in polite
company
well maybe we could I'm pretty much not
not cancelable so go ahead
there's certain topics I feel like if we
bring them up we might get shut down or
canceled
I have been canceled and resurrected so
anyway I think I think we are Beyond
cancellation
um well I wondered if we might not talk
a little bit you raised it several times
already Michael uh about the 911
question
yeah
um and how one is to think about it I I
admit that
um I find this a frustrating topic
because again I see a pattern of
anomalies yeah that uh refuse to
dissipate on inspection
I know that some anomalies should be
expected I think the number of anomalies
is too high which doesn't tell me
anything about what did or didn't take
place but but why is it high it's
because this is the biggest thing that's
happened since the JFK assassination in
our country okay that's why that's it so
it's everybody is examining every little
minute detail
to me it's a distraction the the the the
the theory that it was an inside job by
the Bush Administration it's a
distraction from the real conspiracy
theories like how what who funded the
Saudi operatives why do we have this
relationship with the Saudi government
and you know how is it that those family
members were able to leave the country
the next day you know those are the
kinds of things that if there's an
inside anything it's kind of more of the
real politics of how our relationships
with some of these foreign countries are
pretty questionable but some of the
anomalies aren't little things that God
Unearthed because people are looking
very carefully at every detail like what
well you know it's a cliche at this
point but the way building Seven Falls
doesn't make any sense to me as somebody
does I think so you know and you know
who also knows the insurance companies
they had to pay off they investigated
this if they could have shown something
uh behind it all they wouldn't have to
pay no again I think it's interesting I
think because the insurance companies
that insured the buildings and the
tenants on 911 do you know who that was
it was AIG I forget now who that was it
was convicted in 2008 of running
reinsurance scams where they basically
were reselling the bad insurance
policies so that other insurance
companies would take the hit
so they never never investigated what
happened on 9 11 with the insurance in
the World Trade Center but the the
insurance companies that actually held
uh those policies didn't pay out someone
else took the hit and they were never
investigated for that so that that right
there is a huge red flag
um you know who Cornelius vanderstar was
he's the guy that founded AIG there's a
whole book about them um called The
Secret Insurance men and how the CIA
used AIG to know What factories to bomb
uh to know what um you know where where
the money was flowing in in a lot of
these countries it was it was a great
source of intelligence the insurance
here's a picture from my book of a piece
of American Airlines flight that hit the
Pentagon yeah so we know that the planes
hit the Pentagon we see the videos
unless the videos are supposedly fake
but here's a piece of the in color you
can see it's the American Airlines logo
oh yeah I've seen right there on the
lawn in the Pentagon so so how did the
planes hit the Pentagon and the World
Trade Center buildings who who made that
happen if it wasn't the hijackers and
how did they do that what's interesting
the um there was a drill for a plane
hitting the Pentagon called called Mass
cow the mass casualty drill uh it was an
exercise uh for the pet for a plane
hitting the Pentagon and the person in
charge of that for the Pentagon was a
guy named Charles Burlingame
who ended up being the pilot on flight
77 that crashed into the Pentagon that
day
um now the flight on that flight there
should have been uh I think like 300
passengers 400 passengers that fit there
were only 180 passengers on the flight
and only 200 people in that wing of the
Pentagon that were killed because the
wing of the Pentagon that they struck
had recently been refurbished and uh had
undergone a 258 million dollar contract
in that specific wing of the Pentagon so
a lot of the offices were moved out and
surprisingly none of the workers were
there when the attack happened so none
of none of the amec employees actually
died in the Pentagon attack but there
are a lot of interesting anomalies uh
there for example the people that did
die in The Pentagon the offices that
were left in that area and not moved out
were the a lot of the a lot of Pentagon
uh accounting offices and financial
accounting offices and people have like
you know John
suspicion about you know Rumsfeld the
day before saying that there was missing
trillions and and uh that you know the
people who were tracking that money down
got targeted the next day
um whereas terrorists would likely have
targeted the north wing of the Pentagon
where the command center is and not you
know the recently refurbished Wing so
that was a that's an interesting anomaly
right there this is all interesting let
me ask you some just easy big questions
so we saw the planes hit the World Trade
Center buildings yeah and we saw the
exact floors that they hit at an angle
and that the buildings collapsed from
that point down how would the Inside Job
operators know ahead of time which floor
is exactly to plant the explosive
devices because that's where the planes
are going to hit
well actually the first tower on the
first plane on 911 crashed into the 93rd
floor of the North Tower which is right
where El Paul Bremer's offices were
um now Paul Bremer was the head of
Marshall McLennan companies right and he
was also the director of um counter
terrorism I don't care who's on the
floor how did they know to hit net floor
93 and how could they even aim it that
perfect at an angle
well if you you're that's not it's an
obvious
ly sorry
oh sorry go ahead great go ahead Jeremy
well I'm just saying there's a delay on
your thing apparently okay I'm sorry uh
well he said he's not concerned with you
know who worked in that zone
um but he wants to know who could have
who could have done this
well you should be concerned with who
worked in those buildings and and the
security in those buildings and who
managed the security in those buildings
have you ever investigated that you seem
curious about it
well okay so here's my point because
I've seen your video those buildings how
how are you seeing my uh the truthers
where they all signed a non-disclosure
agreement okay this was somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but but the larger
question would be you could see the
buildings collapsing if they planted
explosive devices in there how would
they know exactly which floors to put
the explosive devices before the planes
you know days weeks before the planes
even took off so it's not obvious to me
that that's a question that needs an
answer
so there may be an answer it's not
obvious to me that you need one because
I know the answer and look I'm I I'm no
expert in demolition but
you could imagine that there were
explosives on all the floors
and that the triggering was arranged
after the empirical fact of the airplane
so but I I do want you to answer that
question but I also want to point out I
said it didn't make sense to me
hold on we're going to come back to that
but I said it didn't make sense to me
how building seven fell and you said of
course it made sense and then
immediately changed sorry so anyway I
want Jeremy to answer your question and
then I want to come back to my question
okay okay Jeremy so you remember in 1993
there was a bomb in the World Trade
Center yep yeah yeah yeah and the FBI
investigated that well they had to make
some repairs to that bombed out section
of the parking garage and that whole
corner of the building where we had all
the the stuff taken out now the company
that was hired to do that was a company
called try data Corporation now try data
Corporation is a subsidiary of another
company called systems planning
corporation international which was run
by the third in control of the Pentagon
that day a guy named zakheim
and try data Corporation would have been
given in 1993 access to all the World
Trade Center's Blueprints and all the
engineering diagrams to be able to
conduct those repairs to the damaged leg
of the World Trade Center that was
damaged during the 93 bombing so
presumably they would have had access to
all of that through
um their connections because they're the
ones who did the investigation of that
and the engineering repairs to the World
Trade Center and it's also interesting
that that company systems planning
corporation international they developed
this awax flight termination control
technology which was able to
it's able to do autopilot GPS augmented
autopilot commands for aircraft is an
early
um an early autopilot controller but
they could basically install this on the
planes and fly them completely through
remote command remote automation or um a
pre-programmed series of waypoints
so what happened to the pilot pilots and
all the passengers
well it's if you can't control the plane
how are you going to eat and you can't
make cell phone calls
I don't know they did make some phone
calls we the family members got cell
phone calls from them yeah
they had them they had voice I got to
tell you Mike Michael that uh those cell
phone calls have never made much sense
to me but but family members
before they died who
aren't we aren't we right back where we
were with uaps where none of us here are
convinced by things that are easily
accounted for by uh readily available
um technology right in other words I
think you think the Bush Administration
made mistake phone calls
I haven't said anything about the Bush
Administration I all I have said whoever
is on calls don't make sense to me the
making of phone calls in 2001 from a
plane uh calls that did not
frustratingly drop almost instantly does
not add up
well that's the theory but that's been
tested and they can make those that they
could have made some of those calls in
any case who were the family members
talking to are these just fake fake
voices no no but see let's see I was
much happier with this conversation a
few minutes ago because Michael you are
now you are now trying to get me or
Jeremy to answer questions rather than
to recognize that there is a pattern of
evidence that doesn't completely add up
well but these are important questions
no they're not they're not unimportant
they're not important questions family
member talks to her husband and he's you
know were you hijacked we're gonna die
oh my God I love you and then boom God
no Michael okay
I'm not telling you
my position is I don't know what
happened on 9 11. okay I don't know if
it was a conspiracy or not however I do
know that the numbers of things that I
can see that don't add up is too large
to be easily dismissed and so I am not
capable of answering these questions
because I don't have privileged
information about what took place but I
will tell you this
if there was some sort of a conspiracy
to create the impression of
the uh mainstream narrative on 9 11.
then the idea that a component of it
involving person X that I don't know
talking to person why that I don't know
in some way I don't understand is not
outside of the scale
if if we're talking about buildings that
behave in ways that don't make sense
then the idea of phone calls that don't
quite add up is Small Potatoes yeah you
know Osama Bin Laden said he did it he's
proud of it they said he tried again and
he did again there's the deep is he
lying there was a young girl
the origins you're trying to get mean to
answer questions when my point is the
number of anomalies here is high okay I
have a question a quick question for
Jeremy the the blue back to the
blueprints so are you suggesting that
operatives broke into through the
drywall and got into where the sport
beams are in the two World Trade Center
buildings and no one noticed them doing
this elevator shafts lots of people
known as Scott Forbes reported power
Downs uh William Rodriguez they had
janitor reported workers in the building
making loud noises in the elevator
shafts there was an ace elevator uh
renovation of the elevator shafts that
took place before 9 11. it was reported
in um uh
elevator Weekly Magazine I believe I
have the article somewhere I could I
could send it here's some magazine
called elevator weekly
I'm a lifelong subscriber elevator
weekly you know uh
is out of curiosity who do you if there
wasn't Al Qaeda who do you think was
behind it
well the first pronouncement of the
official story as as you know we're
saying you know where did the official
story first come from so the first
person to tell us that it was Osama bin
Laden on television that day was a guy
named Paul bremmer on MSNBC that morning
now Paul missed work he he showed up
late on a flight and didn't wasn't able
to get to work
um in the World Trade Center uh where I
mentioned he worked on the 93rd floor
his was his office right where the plane
the first plane struck on 9 11.
um Paul bremmer went on to become the
Iraq occupation Governor so he basically
led the whole invasion of Iraq and um
he was never you know investigated uh
for any ties to to terrorism of course
you know he lost a lot of co-workers in
that building and um you know
it it's it's it's you know I I Noam
Chomsky got very defensive when I you
know accused him of being a potential
conspirator and if there ever if there
was one but uh he draws a lot of red
flags for me because uh what
yeah I had asked Noam Chomsky about this
because gnome is a big disbeliever in 9
11 stuff so I asked him you know and he
his response was well who's who did it
who's responsible then who on the inside
you know could have done it when I said
Bremer he said oh that's the most
ridiculous thing it would have been the
worst decision he could have ever made
in his entire career
um how could you possibly think that you
know he could have been involved and and
uh and whatnot um but it's interesting
that Bremer's involved uh in of this it
goes back to this continuity of
government group that Cheney and
Rumsfeld were both involved in
um and this continuity of government
group's job was to basically sit in
these think tanks with all the Joint
Chiefs of Staff and all the military
advisors and dream up 911 it was their
job was to dream up doomsday scenarios
like what's the worst possible thing
that could happen to the U.S you know
multiple bombs going off what and then
how's the US going to react and that
that was their job for you know several
decades there was a Atlantic article all
about this the continuity of government
program
so if you think about who would have had
the intelligence access within the
inside to you know think this through
and plan this out and see well how is
the government going to react to every
single step of this you know anomalous
tragedy that's unfolding
um those would have been the guys who
would have had access to that
um through the continuity of government
program and and Bremer's you know
proximity to that group you know again
he was a young staffer in the Ford Nixon
administrations alongside Cheney you
know comes from that you know deep state
background
um and then you know some reason winds
up working for Marsha McLennan at the in
the World Trade Center is right before 9
11.
UM also working for this Harvard
counter-terrorism
group and um
you know so he's he's involved in Terror
you know terrorism counterterrorism kind
of activities simultaneous to his
position there and it it falls into
place kind of interesting because you
know he's he's there at March McLennan
CEO and he's there next to a guy named
Jeffrey uh Greenberg whose father is
Maurice Greenberg of AIG
who I mentioned before as being you know
the the sort of secret Insurance men who
were seven years after 9 11 were
convicted of running reinsurance scams
where they basically resold all the
policies they knew were going to fail to
other insurance companies and um
so that they would take the hit on
purpose so you have this sort of uh
Nexus of of very interesting people
um and it turns out if you read on
rumsfeld's resume he worked in buildings
he worked for both of uh Cheney and
Rumsfeld prior to joining the Bush
Administration Administration worked for
Solomon Smith Barney on the foreign
policy Advisory Board and SSB Solomon
Smith Barney Bank was World Trade Center
Seven's top tenant so they they occupied
about 85 percent of that building
which is just an interesting anomaly if
you're if you know when Rumsfeld was
asked you know if he'd ever heard of
building seven he said I'd never heard
of it you know I was too busy with the
Pentagon but it turns out that he he
probably held meanings inside that
building prior to 9 11 through his work
on the foreign policy advisory report
and those are interesting connections
that of course World Trade Center seven
is not even mentioned in the 911
Commission report they did investigated
at all and uh can you can you uh I I
can't do it I've forgotten but there's a
long list of interesting things that
were in building seven
was the most interesting one apparently
the Enron investigation was being run
out of building seven uh into the whole
Enron scandal
the whole um Enron had run of course uh
Finance Bush's run to the White House in
early 2000 and
were later investigated Ken Lay was
indicted and uh you know and I think I
don't know a whole bunch of stuff ended
up going down with Enron but they never
got to the full bottom of the whole
thing and um they're ties to the Bush
Administration and I think all that was
kind of stuff those guys were those guys
were convicted sent to prison what do
you mean there was no follow-up on that
I think that there was much deeper ties
and with whole what was going on with
Enron and the how how they managed uh
Bush's run to the White House and and
all that in in the years before okay so
let me make a few General comments hold
on I
am I correct that the CIA
had a piece of building seven in which
the desk responsible for uh
investigating Osama Bin Laden was housed
no I've never heard that I've heard that
the they had the um
this the Securities and Exchange
Commission within that office they had
the El Dorado task force office in
building six which was an interagency
money laundering Watchdog group that
reported that their their vaults were
actually broken into and raided before
the towers came down like the early that
morning so there's this interesting
anomaly there
um that maybe that money laundering
Watchdog group was targeted I've also
heard of a guy named Richard Andrew
Grove who uh was working for a company
called silverstream International on the
World Trade Center and found uh evidence
of um some of this Fortune 500
accounting software having you know
faulty a faulty drive file in it he
talks about it um on in his some of his
interviews and stuff but he was told to
bring all his evidence of this to a
meeting on the 93rd floor of the World
Trade Center on the morning of 9 11. and
uh fortunately he was late but uh it's
just he thinks that they the basically
the people who were responsible for this
that he had stumbled across some kind of
accounting thing in their software and
when uh they had tried to basically get
him to bring all his evidence to this
meeting where he would have met his fate
um interesting anomalies with that kind
of stuff
um then the security companies
okay
and I'm gonna have to uh run here in a
few minutes let me just make a few
General comments about this so you know
in 911 truth or circles there's two
things called my hop and my hop has made
it happen on purpose why hop is let it
happen on purpose the debate is did Bush
know it was going to happen and let it
happen because this for whatever's mode
or did he actually make it happen on
purpose okay so I coined a new term
called calhop capitalized on what
happened on purpose and my analogy with
Pearl Harbor for example sometimes 911
is called the new Pearl Harbor is there
were conspiracy theories after Pearl
Harbor that Roosevelt either knew was
going to happen and let it happen or he
actually orchestrated some of it and
made it happen on purpose but in fact
the way politicians really work is they
capitalize on what happened so you know
Roosevelt famously wanted to get the
United States into the war Churchill was
begging him to get involved uh in the
war and he just couldn't he couldn't get
the support of Congress the American
first movement was very strong the
general public was not behind it after
the debacle of World War One in our
involvement there so but once Pearl
Harbor happened then everybody was
behind it so he capitalized on what
happened on purpose and there's memos
you know like the famous uh August 9
2001 Memo from Condoleezza Rice you know
Osama Bin Laden to attack the United
States on U.S soil how could the Bush
Administration not responded just a
month before but in fact there were
there were thousands of pieces of Intel
that you know nine or Al Qaeda was doing
this they were doing that attacking our
bases here they were going to do you
know attack over there they're going to
do a bombing suicide order same thing
with with Pearl Harbor you know
Roosevelt had thousands of pieces of
Intel about the Japanese are going to do
this the Japanese are going to do that
there was so much Intel they couldn't
sort through what to make of it all
after the fact you go back and go oh
look there's that piece of Intel right
there on Roosevelt's desk that they were
going to attack in Hawaii it was Hawaii
he knew it was going to happen no in
hindsight yes but so Bush famously W you
know wanted to finish the job of his
father you know in in uh Iraq so you
know he and obviously there was no
reason to do that until 9 11 and then
it's like ah now is my chance so then
all this stuff you have about uh you
know the whole Bush Administration that
then falls into place on the capitalize
on what happened hey good you know
Halliburton and Cheney and Rumsfeld and
the whole gang of course yes they did
capitalize on what happened they
profited from it it was a needless war
and and on all that is true without
having the conspiracy in the first place
it's a different kind of conspiracy sure
sure look that
they capitalized
yeah yeah whether there whether there is
anything beyond that
but it sounds to me like you've got to
go and I do not want to let the building
seven questions
I cannot I cannot see it past okay I'll
just give you a few and I'll address a
few more of these anomalies I got a few
minutes I have to take my dog to the vet
uh well so first of all building seven
burned all day
and so it was usually the pictures you
see are the back side where there
doesn't look like there's much damage on
the other side uh you know it was
totally destroyed from all the debris
that hit it and burned all day and so on
and the fire Crews were there they were
monitoring it watching it and finally
they said pull it you know the head of
the the owner of the building pull it he
just met pulled the the the the fire
team out of there before it collapses
then it collapsed anyway I never thought
that was so unusual but let me just add
a few more of these other anomalies
you did not you did not address my point
I didn't say I don't know why it fell
down I said I can't explain why it fell
down the way that it did it looks to
look if you look on YouTube people on
YouTube explosive you know demolish
buildings in the way that they look like
they fall that's what it it doesn't
neither the World Trade Center buildings
nor building seven uh particularly the
World Trade Center buildings you know
exploring they don't they don't look
like a standard controlled demolition
doesn't mean it doesn't mean that it
doesn't look like a conceivable one but
it doesn't look like a standard control
demolition at all right no building
seven is different and here's here's the
thought experiment I would put to you
the reason that this particular piece of
the puzzle will not let me go is that
when I if I grant you hey it burned all
day it burned way hotter than we know
maybe there was something stored in it
that caused it to burn in a way that
would actually bring down a a steel
frame building like that and nobody has
admitted that it was stored there let's
Grant all that
the way it falls
is something gives way first and it
partially Falls or it slumps over or it
twists or something like that it doesn't
just suddenly descend in the way that
it's captured on video from multiple
angles doing
right that to me is the problem that
even if I say I can accept that it fell
as a result of the unusual amount of
damage that happened that day and the
amount of fire that was unknown and
fires burning at a temperature that
doesn't make sense to me but has some
rational explanation that isn't the
result of collusion I still cannot in my
mind get to the point where it falls in
the pristine way that I watch it fall in
those videos okay I don't want to read
to you four pages from my book but you
know we consulted a guy named Blanchard
who runs a company called Pro Tech that
Brent Blanchard
and his company is called Pro Tech
documentation Services a company that
documents the work of building
demolition contractors anyway so he he
destroys buildings for a living right so
he he gave us all the here's the claims
and the truth is here's his explanation
for it uh for building a World Trade
Center buildings seven yeah he talks
about it burning all day and so on what
about the uh was that it was
intentionally pulled down by explosives
the building owner himself was quoted as
saying he decided to pull it this guy's
answer to that is building owners do not
have the authority over emergency
Personnel at a disaster scene demolition
experts have never heard pull it used to
refer to an explosive demolition
demolition explosive experts anticipated
the collapse of World Trade Center seven
and they also witnessed it from a few
hundred feet away no one heard any
detonations
I think that's a lie because there are
videos of Demolition experts using the
term pull it also it seems more likely
to me he would have said the term pull
them rather than pull it if you're
referring to get the team
the team of people just kind of
confusing yeah I don't think that Larry
had the authority to to make that call
and I don't you know the fact that he
would say that is is sort of out of
place and an anomaly in and of itself
um
outside the um the scope of evidence
that maybe something did in fact happen
because you remember your article for
Scientific American you uh wrote there
was no melted steel and you repeat that
claim in very big letters very many
times on there but there were a number
of FEMA firefighters a number of people
even even I I have the the architect for
the World Trade Center Leslie Robertson
who visited the site very early on
saying that there were streams of liquid
metal trickling like you were in a
Foundry
um very descriptive uh words and
terminology
um which implied that steel was melted
then you have things like appendix C of
the FEMA report where you have a
firewise science Professor Dr Jonathan
Barnett who did the only known study
that was done of metallurgical analysis
of any steel from the towers and
directly in that report he says that
they found um you know chemical sulfide
eutectics which basically is something
you add to Steel which lowers the
melting point of the steel and also they
found evidence of you know that looks
like corrosion and melting of the steel
and he recommended further investigation
to find out what caused that
um a couple of Skeptics like Dr greenier
have suggested that the Gypsy gypsum
drywall
um you know caused the sulfidation of
the steel
um that created that sulfide eutectic
and so we performed some experiments
where we you know burned all kinds of
stuff on some i-beams uh with a bunch of
gypsum board and and tried to get the
Gypsum to infuse and and produce these
same kind of eutectics and uh we were
not able to do that in any of our
experiments
um so it's just uh it seems like there's
a lot of scientific obfuscation on the
behalf of you know forensic
investigators who kept a lot of people
out of the site
limited access to the site uh you know
Kurt sun and field the FEMA photographer
testifying that they they took most of
his photographs and wouldn't allow any
of this stuff to be published in that
the photographs contain almost certain
evidence that explosives were used uh to
bring down the towers
um so you have like this this chain of
evidence that just which has been almost
destroyed and and then polluted after
the fact with people saying you know oh
uh just things that aren't true that
pull it's not a demolition term it most
certainly is I assure you this
well I could go on about World Trade
Center building seven at 47 stories high
and built a red granite masonry wt-7
differed significantly from the World
Trade Center buildings one and two and
those two buildings collapse they're
following debris caused significant
damage to the World Trade Center
building seven which included extensive
fires that burned all day right but but
Michael yeah yeah
I want I want some clarity on this
you're an educated you're an educated
man
I'm not asking you to be an expert in
something you're not expert in
if you run the experiment in your mind
if you cause fires inside of building
seven to burn all day in a way that
structurally compromises it so that it
ends up collapsing
are you telling me that the collapse you
envision looks like the one you saw in
those videos where it falls all at once
like every pillar was cut at the same
moment yeah absolutely this is what all
the experts demolition experts say yeah
no in fact in fact the nist report
refused to discuss how it fell it
stopped its analysis at exactly the
moment it begins to fall you know again
the insurance companies are motivated to
find something you know okay guys I mean
there's the stuff about the you know the
put trades in stocks in the airlines
there was stuff about the cell phone
call I mean I just had pages and pages
on this on the cell phone calls well but
but but and so on I mean these are all
anomalies with explanations
no I I want to get this before before we
have to end this conversation
one thing that is true is there is a lot
of collusion in the world that we
discover later on that becomes
incontrovertible and then there's the
question of before these stories are
understood how we are to think about the
evidence and one thing that is always
true Michael is that
there is always an explanation for each
piece of evidence some of those
explanations sound robust some of them
sound incredibly feeble but the fact
that there's an answer for every
question doesn't mean anything because
of course there would have to be right
okay
the answer to the question of
um were there more weapons than one at
the Bobby Kennedy assassination at The
Ambassador Hotel is there was only one
weapon well if there was only one weapon
why were there more bullet holes than
that weapon could hold well we don't
know that because somebody lost a door
frame right yeah somebody lost a door
how did Sirhan sirhan's gun get behind
and from the back you know to fire that
fatal shot and you know that killed RFK
the shot the people that were standing
there including Rayford Johnson said he
did it you know they saw him pull the
gun and shoot him
some things to research there uh
hopefully
it's an endless Rabbit Hole to go down
uh you know my book covers you know
dozens of conspiracy theories any one of
which you can spend a lifetime doing
nothing but that like JFK all right well
I think that this was terrifically
productive even if it doesn't uh end
with us having resolved all of these
questions uh I think they can't be they
can't be obviously resolved well I hope
they one day can
um for one thing all right gentlemen
many of us need to live in a world in
which we know how to think about these
things but anyway thank you both uh for
joining me Michael do you want to show
your book and tell people oh well the
book is yeah sure conspiracy there it is
uh and you can actually connect the dots
and not only spell conspiracy you can
you can spell CIA and Soros so it's all
there it's all there so uh you have
connected the dots for us thank you and
Jeremy where can people find you
uh my channel is the alien scientist on
YouTube
um I also have altpropulsion.com and
alienscientist.com I don't keep up with
that website as much but feel free to
reach out to me and I'm always available
for you know debates live chats or
discussions and stuff like I enjoy
discussing all these topics and I and
researching them learning new facts so
wonderful all right well may skepticism
and parsimony be with you both I look
forward to part two good I like that
that's a good line all right bye
gentlemen
[Music]